so first of all I want to thank the
panelists from the morning session and
Howard
wonderful keynote and I think we really
have gotten off to a great start so a
few quick housekeeping announcements
that I will repeat from the morning
there's no eating or drinking allowed
inside this auditorium there are
emergency exits throughout the hall
stage left and the doors used to enter
the hall please
silence your mobile phones right now
I didn't hear a few going off before
thank you
audio recording video recording and
photography are not allowed here
so please anyone from the press please
outside they're gonna be representatives
from the Yale Office of Public Affairs
please just check in with them if you
haven't already done so and restrooms
are located on the first floor and in
the basement please contact a staff
member outside if you have difficulty
locating them and finally if you need to
leave the hall and have a small bag
please take it with you and remember
that it needs to be checked again upon
re-entering re-entering the auditorium
and I'd like to remind everyone here
again about the university's policies on
free expression Yale strongly believes
in the rights of individuals to express
their opinions but disruption of a
university event is not consistent with
our policies on free expression so I
want to ask that each person present
respects the right of our speakers to be
heard if a disruption does occur Steve
and I or another University official
will ask for an end to the disruptive
activity and if it doesn't cease within
a reasonable time we might have to talk
to security so please respect this
University policy and if I can add one
other thing for the question period
which you know we will have ample time
for at the end we do ask that you keep
your
questions concise in order to give as
many people as possible the chance to
ask a question so I will now hand it
over to Marcy Shore who is our panel
chair so thank you okay thank you
Maureen for inviting me thank you for
all for being here I am going to limit
my remarks to introducing our panelists
um the first will be Professor lounge
from the University of Oregon he is the
author of from the New Deal to the new
right race in the southern origins of
modern conservatism and he is working on
a project tentatively called the rise
and fall of white populism our second
panelist is Professor Kahn sunny who
seems to have an extraordinary number of
leadership and administration positions
in addition to being a professor she is
a chair of Holocaust Studies the
director of the International Center for
the anti-semitism and Studies Program at
Hebrew University in Jerusalem I will
not read you the title of her books
because my Italian pronunciation is
terrible her current research has to do
with death bracketing death
philosophical and anthropological
analysis of death in the history of the
Shoah
and with eugenics racism and
anti-semitism and our third panelist who
many of you may know is Professor
Jeffrey Alexander who is a social
theorist and a cultural sociologist here
at Yale I may add he has a kind of
particularly enthusiastic nearly cult
following among some of my most beloved
colleagues in the Czech Republic he
works on trauma and social theory and
recently has also been working on the
crisis of journalism and has published a
book called the drama of social life
which is a fantastic title so thank you
all very much for being here
I am now going to turn this over
professor loans who is going to open us
up with a paper called Middle American
radicalism to racial rule Sam Francis
and the political formation of trumpism
Thank You Marcy I want to structure this
presentation around two dynamics okay
I'm back over here this time I want to
structure this presentation as I said
around two dynamics the first concerns
the relationship of the center to the
far right margins of US politics in the
long post civil rights era
the second related dynamic I want to
talk about is that between American
nationalism and white nationalism these
are all within the u.s. context I'll
begin with the first I'm not the first
to say that trumpism extreme as it is in
many respects is firmly rooted in the
legacy of the modern Republican Party
since the late 1960s more specifically
we can trace his legacy from George
Wallace's campaigns in 1964 1968 which
was absorbed into Nixon's silent
majority and then emerged again in the
figure of the Reagan Democrat in 1980
and especially in 1984 well unlike
scholars who see trumpism is merely more
the conservative same like say political
scientists whether there is Corey Robin
or legal scholar Jack Vulcan I think the
current administration has a novel and
distinct relationship to white supremacy
that follows a particular trajectory
from the late 60s to the present modern
republicanism emerged as a cross class
alliances sought to draw middle and
working class white voters out of the
New Deal Democratic Party in the late
60s tying racial animus to net to
economic conservatism this alliance went
under various names the silent majority
forgotten Americans in middle America
among them this populist political
identity as Nixon aide Kevin Phillips
described it in his 1969 book the
emerging Republican majority would bring
together southern segregationists white
ethnics industrial cities in the east
and Midwest Sun Belt conservatives
and Western populist into a durable
assemblage the phrase middle-american
was commonplace at the Nixon White House
Nixon staffers headed up by Pat Buchanan
even began a middle American working
group for presidency increasingly
obsessed with identifying and winning
over this constituency there were
tensions between populist and
establishment conservatives from the
start however the former suspecting the
latter is being interested only in
serving elite interests
the latter seeing the former is
pandering to crude cultural tent trends
and being too willing to embrace old
elements of New Deal statism by the mid
1970s kevin phillips openly rebuked
conservative icon William F Buckley on
behalf of populist s' as he said in the
run-up to the 1976 Republican primaries
held Wallice isn't going to hook up with
squire willy and his companions to the
oxford unabridged dictionary nor can we
expect alabama truck drivers or ohio
steel workers to sign on with the
politics captained by five-syllable word
pushers this political indeterminacy
along with Watergate temporarily soured
the possibility of white populist
finding a stable home in the Republican
Party but a mixture of economic and
cultural issues continued to stoke a
sense of dislocation among working in
middle-class white voters in 1976
Donald Warren a sociologist Donald
Warren produced a study of what he
called middle American radicals in his
1976 book the radical Center middle
Americans and the politics of alienation
Warren described middle American
radicals or Mars the acronym that he
went on to use as largely lower
middle-class white and often urban
ethnic Mars Warren argued had proximate
roots in the Wallace campaign's of 68
and 72 but also in such things as the
more politically ambiguous trucking
strike of 1973 and 1974 Marsh tended to
see both rich and poor as blameworthy
for societal ills as Warren described it
on some issues Mars are likely to take a
liberal stand on others a conservative
one for example the Maher expresses a
desire for more police power he feels
that granting the police a heavier hand
will help him control crime however Mars
are also adamant about keeping many
social reforms often wrought by the
left such as Medicare aid to education
and Social Security and quote but it was
the politics of race that provided the
clear contours of middle-american
radicalism for Warren as he described it
this radicalism was expressed in the
Boston anti busing riots the campaigns
against open housing laws in California
and in law and order mayoral campaigns
across the country such as Frank Rizzo's
in Philadelphia in another 1976 book
this one by Robert Whittaker a plague on
both your houses
he ranted and Wallace I'd tones
attacking those both those above and
below who aligned against the middle
quote in American society is generally
split increasingly into a coalition of
the rich and poor against the middle one
thinks of the Chicano with a picture of
the enormous ly wealthy John Kennedy on
the wall of his Shack meanwhile he went
on Republicans and conservatives make
use of our patriotism to expand an
already fat in inefficient Pentagon to
protect and to protect business from
necessary public scrutiny yet while this
book attacked conservative and business
elites it was anointed with the glowing
foreword by National Review publisher
William rusher and given a rave review
by Jeffrey Hart in the pages of the
magazine and by late in the decade
Republican conservatives actively sought
out this constituency again as Chilton
Williamson wrote in National Review in
1978 quote populist conservatism is
winning far more sympathy from the old
right in the 1970s than it ever enjoyed
in the 60s when it spoken the accents of
George Wallace no doubt this is owing in
part to the tempting success of
President Carter's delicately
orchestrated campaign of beer grits
baptismal water in STP that was a motor
oil fame popular back then
well the Mars described by Warren
largely ended up as Reagan Democrats in
1980 and 84 the tensions in this
coalition between neoliberal elites and
middle and working class whites was open
for some reassociation in fact I would
argue ultimately that one version of a
racial middle America politics gained
expression in the Democratic Party
through the DLC and Bill Clinton who
pander to the quote angry white man and
who made issues of crime and welfare
central to his presidency along these
lines we can also recall campaign
adviser mark Penn's
advice to Hillary Clinton in her primary
contest against Barack Obama in 2008
advising her to target his blackness and
his foreignness he wrote in a memo every
speech you give should contain the line
that you were born in the middle of
America in the middle of the last
century into the middle class and talk
about the deeply American values you
grew up with learn as a child and then
drive you every day but I digress here
for the logic of middle America when in
another direction too toward a more
fully articulated political formation on
the right in 1992 when George HW Bush
was running for a second term fissures
between populist and establishment
conservatives opened up again as the
Republican Party became more identified
with financialization corporate rule in
American Imperial hegemony the old white
populist insurrection reignited the
central figure here is Pat Buchanan who
ran in the GOP primaries in 92 and in
1996 on a self-consciously populist
anti-free trade and to wall street
anti-immigrant and anti-affirmative
action platform buchanan had already had
a reputation for anti-jewish sentiment
and received on-the-ground support from
clan and neo-nazi groups across the
country in his campaign particularly in
the south although he mostly repudiated
the endorsements of these groups the
political formation he engendered open
new territory and racial populism as the
far-right analysts Leonard Susskind said
at the time well Buchanan is catalysed
is a racist movement whether or not he
is personally anti-semitic I don't know
exactly what it will produce but one of
the things I expected to produce is an
extremist conservative movement in which
race ethnicity nativism
and nationalism play a greater role than
the anti-communism of the past
Buchanan's campaigns in 1996 and again
2000 were increasingly marginal but they
helped spur the development of a
populist right formation by connecting
far-right and racist journals
organizations and various of what are
now called paleo conservative
intellectuals one of you cannons closest
campaign advisors was a man named Samuel
Francis Francis was as he described
himself a man of the right perhaps the
far right intellectually Francis was
strongly influenced by both Nietzsche
and Machiavelli and by Gramsci's theory
of hegemony he saw promise and Donald
Warren's Mars is holding
populace possibility of breaking out of
an elite stranglehold on American
society he was also able to put his
finger on something true about
neoliberal capitalism and its ravages he
invented mentee of James Burnham the
former Marxist radical and Trotsky
confidant who went on to become a
leading figure in the American
conservative movement in the 1950s and
60s after writing a book called the
managerial revolution what is happening
in the world in 1941 Francis saw a
managerial new class as having become
the dominant one in the 20th century
acting as the central functionary of
both modern capitalism and the
bureaucratic state and oppressing a
broad working-class Francis wrote in a
1990 essay called from household to
nation the middle and the middle
American populism of Pat Buchanan quote
if the post bushwa middle class
seriously wishes to avoid its own
extinction
it will have to evolve a new group
consciousness and a new identity
independent of both the moribund bushwa
elite and the techno bureaucracy of the
global managerial order and it must
aspire to form the core of a new
political and cultural order in which it
can assert its own hegemony Francis was
actually associated also with the
critical theory journal Telos through
Paul Gottfried which in the 1990s was
pursuing its own new class critique and
taking a turn towards populism via
Adorno Carl Schmidt European new right
thinkers such as Alan J Benoit and
editor Paul Peck oneís own artificial
negativity thesis anyway for all the
sociological and political acuity
Francis brought to his analysis he
increasingly framed his class politics
through a crude lens of white supremacy
new class domination he ultimately
theorized worked first and foremost
against the interests of white people
Francis had urged Buchanan to place
immigration and free trade together at
the top of his platform in 1996 and to
come out strong and defending the
Confederate flag because these issues
spoke directly to the quote racial
dispossession of the historic American
people once a prominent syndicated
columnist at the Washington Times
Francis was fired in 1995 for comments
and an American Renaissance commented
American Renaissance conference where he
boomed liberal humanism
war against the white race and asserted
that whites must
reassert our identity and our solidarity
and we must do so in explicitly racial
terms through the articulation of a
racial consciousness as White's
end quote Francis went on to edit the
newsletter newsletter of the Council of
conservative citizens which is kind of a
child or grandchild of the old citizen
count citizens councils of the 1950s and
60s to work for the League of the south
and to write for increasingly obscure
publications of the far and racist right
as he was pushed further and further
from mainstream conservatism he began
referring to establishment Republicans
as the anti hereditary n'r it-- in
reference to the party's embrace of
colorblind conservatism and rejection of
a genetic basis for race for Frances
alienation from mainstream conservatism
was a small price to pay for having
helped give political shape to middle
America in opposition to the Republican
Party as he said in 1997 what has
happened in the Buchanan revolution is
the emergence of a new political
identity after spending the last years
of his life riding a sprawling opus on
the second floor of robert e lee's
historic home francis died in relative
obscurity in 2005 yet his ghost returned
in 2016 to become an important figure
for the new political identity he helped
forge
his name was evoke by everyone from Rush
Limbaugh to Richard Spencer in relation
to Trump's campaign as his old books and
articles were dusted off and quoted at
length this paleo conservative line
through Francis and Buchanan to Trump is
one way that middle America travelled
across the decades another example makes
Middle America to a more explicit white
nationalism this is the case of Robert
Whittaker who popularized the term white
genocide Whitaker used the term in a
rambling screed he called a mantra that
became a very popular text on the far
right in recent years the final words
anti-racist is a code word for anti
white has become the tagline for white
power propagandists everywhere it deeply
influenced among other people onder's
Breivik the Norwegian white supremacist
who massacred 77 people in 2011 I was at
a meeting of the white nationalist
American Renaissance in Nashville last
month where the term as you can imagine
was repeated endlessly
to describe any form of multiculturalism
affirmative action anti-discrimination
policy or whatever else Whitaker was
also a member of national Vanguard the
fascist group whose membership also
included James fields the man who
murdered Heather hire in Charlottesville
but Whitaker was not merely a figure of
the French right as I mentioned before
in the 1970s he was another important
proponent of Middle American radicalism
his book a plague on both your houses as
I said was important for the emerging
new right and along with national
reviews publisher William rusher he
edited and in Flute an influential
collection called the new write papers
which collectively made the case for a
populist right leading up to Reagan's
1980 election this idea of Middle
America powerfully shaped the u.s.
political horizon across the post-civil
rights era I think in various efforts to
mobilize white voters partly partly
encompassing the elements of clintonism
that I mentioned at the center and
moving rightward ultimately to trumpism
and traveling traveling inexorably to
white nationalism in some sense the
terms majority in middle even for Nixon
were meant to encompass a broad assembly
of Americans beyond sharp racial
definitions and include the mobilization
of other issues not directly rated
related to race including gender
sexuality and religion but race
ultimately defined it indeed the
signifiers majority and middle were
forged as inescapably racialized terms
the silent majority was envisioned as
white and thus the principle of
majoritarian representation would also
have to be even when the racial
adjective is left unspoken the notion of
middle has been similarly racialized as
a term in the logic of populist producer
ISM from the Jacksonian era forward the
virtuous citizen is defined against
elites above in the dependent and
criminal poor below each parasitic on
the body of the nation what is the
notion of white genocide after all but
the idea that the silent majority is no
longer the majority or that the middle
in middle America is being squeezed out
of existence by corporate diversity
promoting new class professionals above
and black and brown people below and
Muslims from outside in fact you can
think of Obama in this in this
formulation as someone who represents
the black below and the elite above all
in one one figure which I think partly
animated this kind of populist racist
hatred for him the idea of white
genocide though I think actually takes
middle America a next logical step which
raises the second relationship I want to
briefly discuss that between white
nationalism and American nationalism a
couple of weeks after Charlotte's bill
in the day before he was fired Steve
Bannon told the American prospects Bob
Kutner quote ethno-nationalism its
losers it's a fringe element I think the
media plays it up too much and we got to
help crush it these guys are a bunch of
clowns many commentators balked this is
a guy who named Roth's Julius Avila and
who loved the racist novel camp of the
saints he the guy who said he made
Breitbart the platform for the alt-right
but the distinction matters here and
it's one that I think is generative for
the right for the far right since the
1980s white nationalists have debated
whether the US could be preserved as a
white dominant nation or rather the
abandonment of the US nation had become
necessary requiring a new smaller
homeland and a few states in the Pacific
Northwest where the American South I
live in Oregon and let me tell you
there's lots of these folks already
making the pilgrimage the separatist
line running from Aryan Nations through
the order through various other
revolutionary white supremacist groups
is the position of prominent white
nationalist formations from Richard
Spencer's National Policy Institute and
Nathan demagogues identity Europa to
American Renaissance such a move shifts
the racist right from an American
national identity to an explicit racial
identity that makes no claims to
American exceptionalism but rather basic
territorial claims for the white race
the other line let's call it middle
American nationalism that America is a
nation founded by and for a white
majority is in some sense a position of
the Trump administration which seeks to
achieve it through police and carceral
control of the black and brown poor a
border wall and massive deportation Sam
Francis for his part opposed both
separatism and segregation is absolutely
unworkable and he also believed that
America could yet survive as a white
dominant nation as he wrote most white
Americans retain
too much sense of nationality and too
much allegiance to their country and
their own commitments to accept a
proposal of giving up Allegiance
to accept the proposal of giving up
large parts of the u.s. to others not
only would wide to be abandoning their
own country they would also be forced to
give up appeals to its history
traditions and interests as a nation we
could no longer argue that immigration
threatens our national interest because
there would be no nation to have
interests he went on to argue that many
of the founders as well as American
statesmen from Jackson through Theodore
Roosevelt and beyond believed in the
superiority of the white race and so why
should white racists as Americans give
all this up I think these two positions
defenses of American nationalism and a
call for a separate white ethno state
are sometimes in conflict but are also
mutually reinforcing the Democrats ban
and went on in his interview with The
American Prospect the longer they talk
about identity politics I got them I
want them to talk about racism every day
if the left is focused on race and
identity and we go with economic
nationalism we can crush the Democrats
this unfortunately is a sentiment that
is also voiced in the so called anti
identitarian Left those who think that a
focus on race takes away from left
universalism whatever happens with Trump
I think we in the US will be dealing
with durable forms of white racial
populism as a distinct force that will
continue to shape the larger political
landscape for a long time to come I
think both in the form of white
nationalism and white American
nationalism thank you
our next speaker is Professor Manuela
consignee
um with a talk titled Julius avala and
the racist rate between past and present
a reassessment thank you you do Savannah
is certainly the most influential figure
of contemporary radical right
it's thought he studied in France
translated in Spain and Portugal in the
United States in the former Soviet Union
my lecture aims to analyze availability
of philosophical and political thinking
without purging it from its problematic
aspect that is without the fascist side
the fascist is izing it to analyze the
two constitutive elements of a vollis
thoughts the meta politics on the one
hand and racism and anti-semitism on the
other while reflecting on the ongoing
actuality or lavalla who became the
recognized maestro since the post-war
period of neo-fascism the one who gave
to the ideology of the radical right
groups their historical legitimacy
nurtured by his thought these movements
in their traditional at the same time
global orientation of founded under a
resurgence of national majority as a
necessity as a political social and
cultural value and on the emergence of
external phobic and chauvinistic
political praxis at the center of which
rules and discuss the myths of ethnic
purity against the contaminating Britain
primary caused of the decade of Western
civilization as we learned from canal
and racist idea have always been tight
and still ever an intimate affinity with
theories of decadence fascinated as they
are by the shattering destruction and
literally interesting the flourishing of
life a valid debate on meta politics and
rationals is not therefore just a
problem of history or graphical
interpretation or a theoretical
discussion
which links a Russia project to a
totalitarian ideology rather it effects
with dangerous consequence contemporary
politics it invests our own present
binding it to the past in a very
indiscernible manner restoring
reflection and issues that we thought
belonged to the archive of history duly
chosen and Rivera was not a huge earnest
it was one of the living leading figure
of Italian political organization and a
founding father of spiritual
anti-semitism his philosophy did not
derive from biological racism rather he
propounded a spirit of racism at the
core of which stood the concept of
tradition as the elective praised for
the construction of race out of Russian
differences is thought encompassing ways
of conceiving conceiving the race issues
race is a reality race is a scientific
concept race is a myth that does not
generate a fictive construction rather
an idea the springs from rational and
irrational element elements which with
their suggestive strength are able to
translate it into action forged by
customs and by common past races is
rooted into in tradition an inner era
tidge which shapes a reddit Eric Eric
turistic share that a collective level
led by social group although according
to a valid a metaphysical ethical
foundation of his racial hierarchy
develops around and no biological an
oxymoronic cause a concept of a race of
the Spirit is organ assisting dr. II in
which the reddit or Korek turistic of
the people are transmitted through the
spirit it is true the internal dynamics
which Forge the somatic aspect
according to a ploutonion modest agenda
brings him back into the mainstream of
biological Antin
it is AmeriCorps for an exclusion of the
Jews from the social body called for the
abolition of the Jewish emancipation for
the transfer of the Jews to Australia to
Africa where they could leave
undisturbed according to their customs
and I ask you to pay attention to this
because you will come back on it
ivana racism and anti-semitism are
rooted in modernity if ever I as other
theories of anti-semitism regard some
aspect of modernity as deleterious
industrialism emptied of traditional
values of the nation cosmopolitanism
abstract thinking they value conversely
other such as technique and science to
make the centenary better between
reaction and modernity better understood
it seems to be useful to use the
category of reactionary modernism as
proposed by F or even I would say a
negative kind of modernism a valid
driving force is the violent opposition
to social cultural economic changes of
which the current anti-european ISM
would sit with its outer key with its
ethnic and racial racist nationalism are
the most significant elements Avella
metabolic meta politics were proposed by
him in a very misleading manner as a
kind of utopia made of spirituality a
political reasons contrary to politics
but this discursive strategy offered by
a valla the complain in the 50s of the
absence of a strong and coherent
theoretical radical right thought
regretting that he was not even able to
create an authentic culture of the right
in the fullest sense of the world
I eat iets a judgement on the present
deliberately intended in order to
disempower his action during and after
fascism and to purify his
and thoughts from it's practical
implication especially from
anti-semitism of which ever land in his
father's wanted to be freed from far
away from the burning grounds of
politics he was forgetting a volatile
guided by the magic hedonism and by the
group of war by the tragic metaphysics
by the protocol of the cells age of Zion
by the meat of blood by the synthesis of
race that the absence of ideological
inconsistency in the radical thought was
indeed being consistent
he was the ideology shared by fascism
and nazism of the primacy recognized to
action rather than to the theoretical
reflection on this aspect is worth to
recall another Italian think of Giovanni
genteel a Mussolini Minister of
Education that in 1926 and I quote
described and said fascism is not a
philosophy much less it is a religion it
is not even a political theory which may
be stated in a series of formula the
significance of posthumous is not to be
grasped in the special thesis which it
from time to time assumes when on
occasion it has announced a program a
goal a concept to be arise into inaction
fascism has not hesitated to abandon
them when in practice they were found to
be inadequate or inconsistent with the
principle of fascism itself the most
rigorous meaning of motsi thought and
action were by the two terms are so
perfectly considered that no thought has
value which is not already expressed
into action and of court a sophisticated
intellectual Isabella knew that in the
radical right the absence of terrorizing
was the result of an ideological
conviction that the action was worth
more than the political program two of
the appeal to me is more than that
Teresa the figure
of militiamen more that of the
intellectual in fact right it's
radicalism as always prefer preferred to
focus its attention as Francesco German
arrow pointed out to an intellectual
type who had made extreme choices the
suicide of Piedra La Rochelle or the
death sentence of Robert Brazil ah who
saw in fascism the poetry of the century
and that of genteel himself executed by
the parties and in Italy in 1944 or the
total isolation of figures are such as
saline and pound an important a
paradoxical aspect of a volunteer
modernist try to show knit
traditionalism consists in the
coexistence of metaphysical and super
historical perspectives of the one end
and of a constant ideological political
intervention on the other in desolation
between the metaphysical inactivity and
the commitment historical political
present between the metaphysical between
pessimism of decadence
of the modern world and the Reich
optimism associated with a will to
restore the lost greatness of its origin
ago banal faint imitation which is
theory of creating elite capable of
replacing the aristocracy it cleans
raise pure lineage the Aryans who
because of democracy run the danger of
being contaminated and destroyed by the
inferior non non Aryans it is it this
ideological attitude that explain is in
an out position in the 30s and 40s
towards fascism and Nazism conceived as
first steps in the direction of a
possible conservative revolution was
ultimate outcome should have been to
return to the Golden Age of the upper
boroughs world of tradition revisiting
Spengler ideas on the cycles of culture
Leiva Bruhl and door came on the
primitive soul gained own on the decay
very Iraqis a ver a matured is a
particular concept of tradition a
concept of meta store achill character
not nostalgia of the past but research
of the principle and values that had to
inform human action in which carried out
on a political level could only give
rise to an order of qualitative racial
differentiation and ends of geography
the opposition between the traditional
world and the world modern world was the
total opposition between truth and
heaven impaired other Ness an opposition
that is measured on a qualitative
met a historical plane that is modern
world and traditional world can be
considered as to a priori categories of
civilization inside the same logic
political intervention must be
understood during the 50s and the 60s he
clearly reflected in ávila thinking the
insistent on the concept of over of
order the coup d'etat causation for
which he was imprisoned for a month and
then release the call to anger Hungarian
Eroica
realism the necessary submission to the
reality in decadence from which only the
individual thanks to a responsible
escape into interior ization
could save himself in the left-hand path
as the traditional way to violence which
privilege an anomic and destructive
behavior the one and I quote from which
the fire of death flares up death with
verges the abyss which seemed to
resemble the working on a sward compared
to the transformation of the poison into
a pharmacon and the court to the
traditional to the left-hand path is
connected the other core of his thought
on racism and anti-semitism over a
process of racialization RT
related in a three-level body soul and
spirit he's far more rigorous and
discriminating that the Nazi biological
racism he defined rosenberg russia
theory as vulgar because it was limiting
its analysis to a purely descriptive
scope which consisted of listing the
physical somatic and topological
features of the races the first degree
of races required of course the use of
natural science that consider the body
data the aspect of the human being
according to which it obeys purely to
natural biological anthropological laws
it was followed by racism of the soul
was task was to identify the elements in
their primary in in reducible ways that
act from the inside rendering the social
grooves bearers of a specific way of
being a style in directing thinking and
feeling between these two degrees of
racism there was of course a
relationship of reciprocity as the race
of the body carried by a given
individual was the proper expression
conforming to the race of the soul and
vice-versa the third degree of racism
correspond to the race of the spirit
identified by avala in the upper human
strength the race of the spirit and I
quote is the pursuit of race according
to its ultimate root root already
communicating with perhaps super
personal supernatural metaphysical the
specific way of conceiving both the
sacred and the supernatural the relation
the relationship of men with respect to
it the vision of life in a tired sense
for which world of symbols and mates are
such positive and objective matters as
for the racism of the first degree are
the fascial in this fashion indices and
the cranial structure essentially in
this domain the sign of the vertical
restore our sensitive the characteristic
sign of disappear arrays are the union
of spirit and power in a synthesis of
calm a secure domain of readiness to
action of a sense of centrality of
unawareness which naturally imposes on
the outside simultaneous veneration and
terror as it happened in every
manifestation of the sacred so far so
that this race is not really born to the
command and to the royal and imperial
function and not limiting the rational
investigation to the bodies but
extending it to the interiority to the
soul and then to the spirit to every
degree correspond the third-generation
crackdown in the upper races the notion
of race is closely linked to that of
tradition and it is tradition in turn
that recognized the presence and the
effectiveness of meta biological
metaphysical super rational and super
violent forces so evil Aras ISM is not
arrest season with a human face that led
the reigns of the fairy tale the
historian of fascism in his history of
Italian Jews commissioned by the Italian
Jewish community 1961 to write in a
quote able in turn also rejected
theorization of racism solely blind
biological so much so to attract that to
attract the attacks and the sarcasm of
vilandra with Alondra was a racist Aries
and unto an Italian anthropologist
stating this the Felicia says I do not
want to say that the spiritualistic
theory of the race was acceptable but at
least it had the privilege of ignoring
certain values rejecting German
aberration trying to keep racism on the
ground of a cultural issues from here
the Felicia concluded that Mussolini
meant rationalism a
racism in a completely different way
from the dances in a creative and
spiritualistic manner which had nothing
to do with anthropology and biology it
is not by chance that avala and Oliver
of followers adapted quoted the Felicia
and now Zelman to reinforce their
apologetic thesis in an attempt to move
away from Italian fascism and from Avada
the weight of the crimes committed
during the war by assuming the
distinction by built by fascism itself
for political ideological goals
especially after the war between good
spiritual racism and bad biological
racism suggested the judgment of value
between a respectable and a good nature
of fascism
these are via criminal Nazism actually
fascist racism was not just spiritual as
the Nazi one was not only entire
biological eyvallah racism was not a
positive one not only because it did not
exclude biological racism but because it
boosted it with the support of the
racism of the spirit the definition of
racism and anti-semitism of the Spirit
is historically inadequate a concept
that aims to end with the passive
acceptance of a restrictive image
elaborated by Everly himself in a
defensive self reprehensible mirror as
it appears in the writing after the war
the place commonly deployed in the nail
fascist and radical rites is that racism
and anti-semitism were a short
parenthesis or level of thinking
definitely closed in 1945 the opposite
is true
racism and anti-semitism are the central
nucleus of ávila thinking which are
inseparable linked to the tradition
which they shape a field with the
left-hand paths
racism anti-semitism tradition and the
left hand part evolved after the war and
completely over a resume all these
anti-semitic arguments and apply them to
the
for Americans and indeed in an
overwhelming and excessively Geraghty
that never had been reached before ever
the differential a mix of far be racist
supported of apartheid and deportation
of Jews and a laughter after Americans
after obsessed with the idea of Nagar
ization of American society is word in
the contamination of white civilization
on the edge of dying under the pressure
of democratic liberty wrote in 1957 and
I quote we are here before an eager
ization a misty cessation in a
regression of the white race before the
inferior more prolific races we know of
the Zeeland intransigence show in a
united state by the advocates of the
so-called racial integration which can
only further be favoring the current
situation moreover they are not only
promote full racial and social promise
pity they also want the Negroes to have
access to any public and political
office so that in the future a Negro
president may also be expected in the
United States but they do not object
the [ __ ] mingles their own blood with
that of the white race people the
imposition of integration is an
outrageous defense to the principle of
freedom here the race factors entered
the question only secondarily a family
has never been denied the right not to
accept and to keep away those strangers
that they found unpleasant but
promiscuity
with [ __ ] in public life is instead
imposed in the name ironically of
freedom on one way freedom why advocates
the integration they did they advocates
of integration do not demand that one of
the fifty states of the Union be
cleansed and sold out to the other
Americans to put them all there in order
to allow them to do whatever they want
without bothering on cotton
contaminating anybody else it is word to
remember
that is racist project was never pursue
as a model of knowledge based on the
concept of race born on natural and
objective scientific hypotheses with a
vision according to which human beings
are a priori not equal and they are by
nature divided into inferior and
superior races it was evil it will
always was a political project that aim
to destroy human life a Belarus ISM and
anti-semitism is not by chance forgotten
and dismissed by the radical right and
too often overlooked by
historiographical research thank you
very much thank you our third and last
paper is by Professor Alexander that the
title is raging against the
Enlightenment the ideology of Steve
Bannon in February of this year Steven K
Bannon was called Trump's brain in the
cover story Time magazine man about him
David Duke former Grand Wizard of the
KKK identified Bannon as quote the
individual who's basically creating the
ideological aspect of where we're going
and as toufic helpfully explained
ideology is ultimately the most
important aspect of any government Danna
had been an informal advisor to Donald
Trump since in 2011 in August 2016 in
the darkest moment of Donald Trump's
presidential campaign he took over and
allowed it
Winn he joined Donald Trump's White
House in January 2016 as chief
strategist departing in August whether
or not Bannon continues to be a
important if Subrosa adviser to trump
and he probably is his long association
with the president his formative
influence on the foundation of the trump
presidency his position as chairman
executive chairman of Breitbart news and
his newfound and extremely dangerous
celebrity status as the most important a
radical right ideologist in the United
States all demand that we examine
bandhans ideas today we need to look
beyond bannon's bitterly sardonic
soundbites and his and the photos of him
you none button barber and muffled cords
we need to look under the hood of
famines mind what is the ideology of
Steven Bannon actually like I believe
that Bannon is engaged in a bitter
struggle against the ideas and the
spirit of democracy when he references
big thinkers he's a brilliant
intellectual and voracious reader his
admirers claim Bannon gestures admiring
Lee to fascists bigots dictators and
theocrats Charles more off for example
the rabidly anti-semitic french catholic
political intellectual fan of Mussolini
and Franco leader of the anti Dreyfus
ARDS who persecuted the French army
captain falsely accused of treason
decades-long agitator against the
Democratic and
ocular third republic sentenced to life
imprisonment after World War two for
collaboration or Julius Avila Italian
professor at the weird but aptly named
school of fascist mysticism ferociously
anti-semitic intellectual and spiritual
advisor at times to Mussolini Godfather
of the racial laws that sent thousands
of Italian Jews to their deaths
alongside admiring allusions to such
heinous ly reactionary intellectuals one
finds nary a reference amidst bannon's
many words to icons of American
democracy such as Washington Jefferson
Lincoln Theodore or Teddy Roosevelt John
Dewey or even Ayn Rand Bannon sees
himself as an outsider just like the
political heroes he has cinema ties such
as Regan Palin and Trump and just like
all the mythical lost men whom candidate
and then President Donald Trump under
bannon's direction has ostensibly
dedicated himself to resurrecting the
sense of being left behind of being
dissed and excluded by the establishment
has fueled and Bannon not just
resentment but powerful anger the kind
of lifelong supercharged aggression that
creates extremists sociopaths and
assassins
his younger brother recounts that even
as a boy Bannon like Trump couldn't get
enough of fighting as an adult Bannon
has been described as a screamer from
whom everything has to be a fight he
loves the idea of war recounts his long
time how
would collaborators Danone himself tells
audiences quote you have to have the
fighting spirit of a warrior and he has
described the ethos of his influential
megaphone Breitbart news in this way our
big belief one of our central organizing
principles at the site is that we're at
war it's a war it's war every day we put
up America's at war America's at war
were at war this furious fighting from
behind mentality certainly qualifies
Bannon as an ideological leader of the
contemporary American right since the
days of such progressive reformers as
Theodore and Franklin Roosevelt and more
fervently and frantically since the
1960s conservatives have been flaying in
frustration at what they see as the
seemingly inexorable expansion of
liberalism social cultural sexual
environmental and political
conservatives have reached the highest
perches of political power
from Nixon to Reagan Bush's one and two
and of course Donald Trump but even the
full force of conservative state power
has failed to stop the steady march of
social incorporation from industrial
workers in the 1930s and Jews in the 50s
to blacks Hispanics Asians women
immigrants and non-conforming
sexualities in the lawn 20th century
from the 60s until today it's impossible
to underestimate how the dis failure as
extraordinarily as rarely acknowledged
has infuriated America's cultural and
political right it has made them rabid
with rage and this anger has boiled over
with the decades-long decline of
American global power China's rise
stalemated military ventures a
globalizing post-industrial economy that
rewards
education and punishes the unskilled and
eight years of the high profile
unflappable and deeply polarizing but
also unusually effective reign of
America's first african-american
president by the middle of Obama's
second term the American White was
beside itself with frustration Steve
Bannon Donald Trump and the alt white
alternative right new right far-right
were the result bannon's ideology is
constructed around binary codes and
temporal narratives the former deeply
authoring the latter dangerously
frothing ly frothing ly apocalyptic at
the core of Bannen ideology is a series
of extraordinarily sophisticated and bad
sacred and profane this series creates
dangerous others whose continuing
existence threatens the good folks who
make up what Bannon describes as the
real America Bannon keeps scorn on
non-white immigrants Hispanic East Asian
South Asian and purifies the people he
describes he describes his Native
Americans these are all quotes this
fantasy category most definitely of
course does not include our nation's
actual natives America's indigenous
quote Indians much less frequent much
less than most culturally American
racial and ethnic group of all African
Americans what are some of the other
simplistic binaries that animate Bannen
ideology nationalists are sacralized
globalist despised
property is praised poverty considered
evidence of disqualification religion is
given a god smacking yes secularism
disparagingly framed always Christianity
is equated with godliness and
civilization and while Bannon sometimes
remembers to add the Judeo agent
as in judeo-christian civilization
neither Jews as a people nor Judaism as
a religion is part of balanced view of
the national mainstream as from
non-western world religions most
especially Islam Bannon dismisses them
as ungodly barbarian enemies of Western
civilization and let's not forget our
national elites vilified as rootless
cosmopolitan selfish and self and rate
enriching Bannon contrasts these elites
with the people that vague mysterious
pious entity he and other populace so
reverently evoke in a democratic social
order the adversarial conflict between
partisan opponents is agonistic not
antagonistic Bannon sees that otherwise
there's no space for comedy in his
universe just as there is no room for
supranational governance there is no
space for constitutionally authorized
third parties to mediate conflicts on
the domestic scene there can be no
mutually binding rules of the game we
find ourselves in Nixon land a world of
plumbers spies and liars of fierce
extra-constitutional confrontations with
Congress press and courts Clausewitz
remarked that war is politics by another
means Bannon sees politics as warm by
another means no wonder he has vowed
that quote every day every day it's
going to be a friend Bannon leaves these
dents tensely opposed binaries into an
apocalyptic narrative that pits good
against evil and a faithful bloody
battle to the death in his 2004
documentary about Ronald Reagan in the
face of evil Bannon condenses his long
list of dangerous others into a meta
antagonist that drawing from the Old
Testaments book of Daniel he
metaphorically eye
as the beast against a dark may launch
of martial images and music the film's
narrator recalls the blood lust killing
and desperation of World War one
dramatically and toning from this fever
swamp grows the beast ominously
referencing the dark side the voiceover
recites Bolshevism fascism communism
Nazism Lenin Mussolini Hitler Tojo and
Stalin is clear that bannon's beast is
less about history than the present
those who have occupied the dark side
are beasts Jill his narrator explains
because they sought control of the state
not for the sake of value but quote
power as an end in itself
they were the secularists and
Cosmopolitan's of their day their
Nietzschean will to power creating what
Bannon would later termed the
administrative state the Beast is
bannon's face of evil and its ferocious
in the course of the 20th century the
Beast grew stronger and stronger it
feasted not only on the real America but
on generations of weak-kneed liberals
too cowardly pathetic materialistic and
pleasure seeking to stand up to the
monster in March s war only Ronald
Reagan knew quote how to confront the
Beast a radical with extreme views quote
Reagan was the only true outsider
elected in the 20th century bannon's
narrator intones faithful Christian from
the hinterlands anti-communist gutsy
crusader for God and country modeled
Reagan won the Cold War and saved the
day and not a second too soon for the
apocalypse was imminent
now three decades after being saved by
Reagan bannon's America is back in the
worst kind of trouble in generation zero
his 2010 documentary that sentiment Isis
the pseudoscience of generational appeal
Oh proposed by William Strauss and Neil
Howe bannon's narrator ominously warns
history is seasonal and winter is coming
we face he says the crisis the time of
final reckoning what we do now
determines whether the American
experiment fails or succeeds if the
right prevails it will lead in house
words to a new founding moment in
American history if the left wins out
America is finished violent times
require violent tactics in speech after
speech interview after interview movie
after movie
Dannan connects his prophecy of the
coming quote radical upheaval with
aggressive often violent confrontation
quote I want to bring everything
crashing down destroying all of today's
establishment Bennett has characterized
himself as a Leninist
and he has linked at the Weathermen the
militant Maoist who tried to convert a
ferment the violent overthrow of
capitalism in the toilet of the 60s
Dannan is not a conservative he's a
revolutionary philosophical
conservatives
such as Edmund Burke poor Michael
Oakshott despised radical in apocalyptic
thinking championing common-sense and
incremental change Bannon has none as
having none of that
proclaiming darkness is good he likens
himself to such pulverizing figures as
Darth Vader Dick Cheney and Satan
himself
it's true in 1973 a Frenchman named
genre spy published a novel called camp
of the saints it painted a
phantasmagorical story about brown and
black immigrants destroying Western
civilization literally an Indian
demagogue called the turd eater leads an
armada of 800,000 impoverished
dark-skinned Indians from the
subcontinent to Europe southern shores
when I'm panning across the countryside
these quote dark hordes proceeded
northward multiplying exponentially
raping white women and killing white men
finally they take control of major
cities Paris London and eventually in
New York in 1975 Scribner published an
English translation splashing across its
cover in large capital letters the
book's title above the book's title a
chilling novel about the end of the
white world the English publication met
with withering reviews to wit this
observation by Kirkus the publishers are
presenting the camp of the saints is a
major event and it probably is in much a
sense that mine comp was as well the
novel went quietly out of print so why
bring up an obscure book forty years
after his failed publication because in
1983 camp of the saints was back in
print
thanks to hefty subsidies from white
wing donors and republished two more
times since it has gained a cult
following among the online off right
this is where Bannon comes in time and
again this all-white ideologue has
employed camp of the Saints as a
metaphor to Frank immigration in our own
times quote it's been almost a cap with
a sense type invention to settle and
then eastern and northern Europe down in
the jaw
in October 2015 it's not a migration
it's an invasion I called the camp of
the saints he explained in January 2016
I mean this is camp of the Saints isn't
it he rhetorically asked an interview in
April 2016 going on to suggest that the
refugee crisis quote didn't just happen
by happenstance these are not war
refugees it's something much more
insidious going on a conspiracy a
dark-skinned demagogue and Armada an
invasion I've entitled this talk waging
against the Enlightenment because it's
vital to see I think that Bannen
ideology is deeply embedded in what
Isaiah Berlin famously called the
counter enlightenment the line of
thinking that challenged the
emancipatory human to human ism upon
which democratic politics and a hopeful
or at least a hopeful view of modernity
are based
Dannan I believe is an ideological error
of the intellectual backlash against
modernity that has been unfolding really
since the counter-reformation
he is the foe of ideas institutions and
movements that idealized the universal
and wave utopian banners about truth
liberty and equality but Bannon is more
and less than a self-taught intellectual
so what is he let's see as far as
political reality goes a political
critic observed its bannon's movie were
in it and the opening credits have just
started to roll the secret abandons
power over Trump and over some large
swath of the American people has been
his myth Oh poetic abilities I'd argue
writing the script setting the stage
finding the actors and directing the
meson sense so effectively that
anti-democratic ideas have for many many
Americans come to seem sensible and
sometimes even inspiring while
democratic ideas appear irrational and
profane banning is a mythologist he
scripted and produced a new and
pernicious political movie which he is
continuing to shape and direct perhaps
even more powerfully democracy is
sustained by a discourse that celebrates
autonomy rationality and moral equality
and by independent institutions that
occurs skepticism participation and free
expression Trump has made visible by
Bannen wants to convince us that
Universalist discourses outmoded and
independent institutions dysfunctional
he spouts bannon's authoring binaries
and he attacks core democratic
institutions journalism is fake public
opinion polls fixed courts biased voting
isn't dispositive office isn't binding
Trump and Bannon are participating in a
political process that democracy has
constructed but their aim is to destroy
it thank you
[Music]